It's weird because normally for animals,
what would be in the
box of what should be,
would be deep motivational states
that are biological in origin.
So maybe an animal
hasn't had enough to eat.
And so park it's feeling hungry.
That's undesirable.
It wants to have something to eat.
And so these different
underlying biological systems
like hunger and thirst and
and sexual lost and aggression and
temperature regulation and so on.
They are what set the goals
and the perceptual frame.
So,
and the emotional responses.
But in human beings we're so damn abstract
that we can take that structure and
we can put almost
anything in that goal box.
So for example,
you can go to a soccer
game and you can say,
well I'm going to identify with my team.
So you expand the boundaries of your
current state of existence to incorporate
the team.
And then you say,
well it's really important to me that
these kicked that little round sphere
through that net.
And so your whole nervous system says,
okay,
well if that's the goal,
we're going to align
our emotions with that.
And then you know,
guys you don't know,
run down the field and kick a little
sphere through a nat and you're like up
there,
you know,
is celebrating in a way that you'd
never do in your actual life.
It's like you don't do that when
you get a good grade on an exam,
you know,
jump up in the air and
hug all your friends.
It's,
you'll do that at a soccer game.
It's like what the Hell is wrong with you?
So,
but you do that because this is a very
malleable and extendable frame and you're
using it for everything.
When you go into a movie theater
and you watch the protagonist,
you basically adopt his or her frame
of reference and then you see the whole
world that's portrayed on the screen
through the eyes of the person that you're
identifying with as part of
our capacity for imitation.
So basically what you do,
what it seems,
what you do there,
it's like if you're talking to someone
else and you adopt their frame of
reference,
it's not exactly a cognitive operation.
What you seem to do is first of all,
come with to some understanding
about what it is that they want.
And so that's the goal.
Once you know what they want,
you can represent them in your body.
So it's almost like you're playing them
as a simulation on your own biological
platform.
And then you can infer from your own
emotional responses if you also simulate
the situation that they're in,
what their emotions are,
and that enables you to
understand other people.
So were these weird biological computers
that are capable of running other
psyches on our biological platform.
And that makes us able to imitate
and also to understand each other.